Graficar la desigualdad,
"y" menos "4x" menor que -3...
-3.
Ok, así que la primera
cosa que debemos hacer es,
poner esta desigualdad en la forma
"mx" más "b"
es decir, por ejemplo empezamos con "y"
menos "4x" menor que -3
de aquí sumamos "4x" de ambos lados
ok, sumamos "4x" de ambos lados,
y lo que nos queda...
es del lado izquierdo es que estos
dos se cancelan y nos queda
"y" menor que "4x" menos 3
ok...
vamos a... sí, vamos a dejarlo así
"4x" menos 3
que es la forma digamos
más familiar que tenemos
"4x" menos 3
y ahora podemos intentar graficar esto pero primero quiero que chequemos algo muy cuidadosamente
voy a dibujar mis ejes éste es el eje "x",
el eje horizontal
y este es el eje vertical, el eje "y",
ok, aquí está,
y queremos ser cuidadosos porque,
este es,
el "4x" menos 3,
no va a estar  incluido en la solución
o sea, "y" igual a "4x" menos 3,
no está incluido
pero bueno,
esto lo que nos va a dar...
es eh...
digamos la solución de esto,
es toda el área debajo
de la línea "y" igual a "4x" menos 3
así que vamos a intentar dibujar la línea frontera,
así que la línea frontera más o menos parecería,
algo así, la frontera
la frontera sería,
"y"  igual a "4x" menos 3
y notemos que esto no es parte de la solución
porque este es un menor estricto,
pero nos va a ayudar a dibujar esencialmente toda la solución,  como su frontera,
asi que,
tenemos aquí la pendiente
y aquí la  intersección con el eje "y"
así que
también podríamos tomar dos puntos y eso nos ayudaría a definir una sola línea
entonces digamos por ejemplo tomemos
un par de valores de "x"
digamos cuando "x" vale 0 esto es
4 por 0 menos 3 que es -3
ok, que de hecho es nuestro punto de
intersección con el eje "y" ¿verdad?
entonces tenemos aquí nuestro punto 0, -3
Y digamos ahora que cuando "x" es igual a...
no sé, digamos...
vamos a ponerle a 2
entonces tenemos 2,
bueno 4 por 2 es 8 menos 3 es 5
entonces cuando nos vamos a "x" igual
a 2 y subimos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
ahi tenemos este punto
y ahora simplemente unimos
estos dos puntos con una línea
o también podríamos este...
decir, bueno,
por cada uno que nos movemos en "x" avanzamos 4 ¿verdad?
eso es lo que nos está diciendo la pendiente, entonces,
aquí ya podremos dibujar claramente la línea,
y lo hacemos de forma punteada porque recordemos que ésta,
esta línea no es parte de la solución.
Ok, me moví un poco...
Entonces tenemos estos tres puntos
que pasan por la línea
ok, lo voy a dibujar con una línea punteada,
y se va a ver algo más o menos de esta forma,
que por cierto, otra vez,
no es parte de la solución
la solución son todos los
"y" menores que está recta
así que si ponemos un "x" aquí,
ok,
entonces de la "y" que está
o del punto que está en la línea,
nos vamos a tomar todas las "y" menores a esas
así que,
en realidad estamos tomando toda esta área.
ok no estamos incluyendo la línea y por eso le estamos poniendo de forma punteada
también puedes intentar algunos valores de fuera ¿no?
digamos este...
a esto nos divide en dos regiones,
por ejemplo,
podríamos probar esto tomando al menos un punto fuera de la región como el 0, 0
ok, por ejemplo este punto el origen el, 0, 0,
tenemos que si "y" es 0
y "x" es 0  tenemos 0 menos 3
finalmente 0 es menor que -3
que claramente no es el caso ¿verdad?
esto no es cierto
no es cierto
y tiene sentido ¿verdad? porque el 0,0
se sale del área que define nuestra solución.
Ahora digamos vámonos del otro lado
algo... eh...
digamos este punto,
el 3,0,
este es el 2.0...
entonces el 3,0 será éste
este debería funcionar porque está dentro de la región ¿verdad? pero vamos a verificarlo
entonces si "y" es 0
en este caso es 0 y es menor que
4 por  "x" que en este caso es 3
-3
y tenemos 0 menor que 12 menos 3...
0 menor que 9,
lo cual es cierto siempre
así que estos satisface la desigualdad,
en general
esto nos dibuja la línea frontera
lo dibujamos de forma punteada,
porque no estamos incluyendo lo en la solución,
porque es un menor estricto,
así que la desigualdad va a ser
toda la región debajo de esta línea
de la "4x" menos 3.